哈喽同学们看得到我吗
哈喽哈喽
大家我大家问题其实不少
我调整一下画面
这是什么东西
这只是新功能
那我先上面看到一些问题
我们就先来
来聊一下
Microsoft日线超美破底翻
隔壁直接跳上去
像被女友戴绿帽
等一下等一下
你的形容词怪怪的
我总觉得怪怪的
好不好
你还有备胎
日线也是超标准破底翻
你是很标准的脚踏两条船
你又要这个又要那个
对吧
我们来看一下Microsoft
Microsoft
我只用MS
来 Microsoft
隔天直接上去吗
你隔天只有这个地方有机会吃
只有这里
只有这个隔天有机会吃
但是现在
你这边看到这些下影线
你现在这附近吃
其实我觉得也不为过
也OK啊
我调一下画面
这样我再看得到
所以其实你现在
但如果你要吃 你就是画一个宽宽大大的打击区
393,397
这整块区域都是你可以做的事情
因为如果你从周线来看 就差不多是这样
周线就是这一区啊
我画歪了 你知道我的意思
然后有人说我有买SpaceX吗 有
但是我不是真的为了要干嘛 为了要赚钱而买
我只是为了让它跳出来
跳在我的持股清单上
因为我觉得我不想要立刻吃
你看我吃在这里
我吃多少来
两股
因为我不打算吃
我的目的只是我吃的
它就会跳到我的持仓的清单内
所以这些交易
它再怎么跌
160块全跌掉我都无所谓
好不好
这是我还会再多观察一段时间
才有可能真的用我们标准的角度去进场最近他太疯狂了那我会等市场沉淀一下甚至我希望等市场比较明确的这种杀杀了几段以后
我习惯看到杀以后的事情
等那个以后我再来做
那这个同学说的这段话
我觉得蛮值得拿出来聊的
我这个帽子哪里买的
我忘记了耶
我真的忘记了
帽子很多
忘记了
不是在美国
不是在稻奇那边买的
是说如果你有去
去洛杉矶那边玩
他那边有一些商店
他可以刺绣
你可以让他绣那个大古香品的签名
绣在上面的这样
然后就是叫他刺绣
然后去逛一逛街
然后再回来拿
然后就好了这样
来看同学的问题
你说不要在多方军队走很累的时候
继续做多
这几天NQ持续的涨
还是需要进场切成小刻度
找做多多机会吗
来
我给你看几个东西
我先看我今天的交易
来我今天的交易
这是我错过这一段
这里下午三四点这边
我错过这个这么好做的这一段
所以早上做了一段
然后这里加码了一下
然后打平
后面这边吃
这里又做加码
反正我的目的就是想要冲出去
对不对
哎呀失败了
然后这边刚刚在赌这个开盘价
失败了
所以目前是亏236
我这个账号我直接给大家看
我都有叫出来
这个账号是这个
这个
这是我
这个账号目前的样子
更新一下
我应该是可以叫他
好了反正我今天赔200多块
他今天还没有写进来
我还没更新他
反正目前的账号的样子是长这样
对好不好
待会这根停住的隔壁
我可能会有想法
现在8点49了
好耶
怎么可以这样就跑掉
好拉下來鎖這裡
這也跑太快了是不是各位按的你们很夸张我才刚按下去而已好吧
那
你看一下我刚刚在做的事情
我并没有被大趋势怎么样困住
所以我给你一个很简单的解法
第一个
你要先搞定
你要做的是哪一个刻度的事情
什么叫哪一个刻度
例如说
我这个是做5K的单子
所以我在60K的大格局的下面
60K我们看一下60K
我在60K
我在60K大格局的下面
好
对吧
然后60K大格局的下面
我看到5K看到我熟悉的东西
而且这个边界
刚刚黄色这条线
刚好又是开盘价
今天的一大早6点钟开盘
那一瞬间的开盘价
所以我就是直接这样子吃进去
我知道我在赌
但是我赌的算是有道理
我在大科读的边界
所以如果你是做5K的单
你看60K就够了
60K有整理 有下沙
好 就可以吃了
当然有下沙以后
这边还是要等图干嘛
这个该要做的事情还是一样
但是就差不多了
对吧
如果你是做的是做日线
来我给你看我也有日线单
我的日线单在这边
这是我的日线单
这里
之前这边各种不赔
再玩玩看反正之前有钱
然后呢
后面这边我这边中间都没有做
对日线来说
我进到60k好了
来
我还没有一个像样的60k的回档
甚至它有可能回挡到这个地方
我才然后打出尖尖的
我才有可能会想要在日线的这个边界去做交易
所以对于我还要进场来讲还远的
而且现在这个月份的这个合约的结算日
比较另类是礼拜四
因为我同学跟我说礼拜五是美国放假
那既然美国放假
它的结算日会在礼拜四
所以通常在结算前
如果我不小心吃到这样子的部位我没有打算要再加因为结算我知道是容易震荡的所以我需要很明确的交易计划
就是我做哪一个科度
我就照着那个科度的事情做
所以如果我在做5分k
那我就照着5分k跟60k的事情做
就这样
那如果我不是在做5分k
我是做15k
那我就是15跟60
那如果我的进场刻度是60k
那我就是60搭配日线
那我永远都会是在
假设这个是日线图
日线涨到这个地方的时候
我一样会在日线这个地方
做我要我熟悉的交易
所以你说如果做
找做空的机会感觉违背趋势
没有啊
你不要管趋势到哪里
你要管的是管
假设
我先把我眼前的这些线先拿掉
才不会干扰
来
假设你喜欢做空
对吧
那你在
这个附近
你看到什么
这是五分K的边界
你看到什么东西
你有没有看到一个
涨不破的地方
跌不破
又跌进来这个
有点厚度的区域里面
所以如果你是在这附近做空
你就守这个910上面这里
我没有什么意见
因为你做的地方又是人家的满足区
而且涂鸦的惯性也真的有掉进来
掉一个颗度下来
对吧
如果是你在这种地方做空
然后又是大颗度的
我先标一条线在上面
我标一条线在这里
然后我们到大颗度去看
那条线
在早一点的这些地方
它又是大颗度上不去的地方
对吧
所以在短线的这个地方
你去做那个空单
我觉得很合理
完全没有什么问题
这样可以理解我的想法
对不对
所以你做的是做
你就照着你的计划做
那你很有可能会被停损
那停损之后来注意
停损之后千万不要做这件事
我就用我的单字
你把它反过来想
好不好
假设我等一下被停损
会是咚咚
这样打在这里
对不对
然后行情会在这边震荡
千万不要做这件事
例如说我是这样被打掉
这样被打掉 假设是这样子把我打掉
涂鸦涂成这样子 结果又有两个下影线再吃
然后又再把我打掉 再一次 又再把我打掉
又有两个下影线再吃
所以你就会变成是有吃吃 然后打掉 吃吃 打掉 吃吃 然后又打掉
连续可能在30分钟内连续打掉三次
这个已经完全跟我们的交易的逻辑完全不一样
这只是在报仇
复仇者联盟的那种感觉
你就是不爽而已
就是这样
好不好
所以你就做你该做的空单
例如说你坐在这边
然后拉一个不赔
然后结果被这边打掉
打掉以后注意
后面这边就没有空单的机会
你只要能够打掉以后
缩手
后面就没有你的事了
对吧
而且我很习惯
例如说假设我真的在这个地方让我吃到这个空单
这空单行情一出去
就是例如说有一根黑棒跌下去
跌到这个下面我跌破这个跌下去
我会把我的风险拿掉
我会把这个本来有这个风险对不对
我会把我的停损从从这个地方拉到我的成本价
可能这边就像我现在做的
现在做还有点早了
坦白讲 但是我可以拉靠近一些的
因为我觉得可以不用手那么远的
这样
那待会如果这边整理的起来
然后呢市场有一根像这样子的K棒
像这样子
有一个像这样子的K棒走上去
这么明确的K棒走上去
我就会把我的风险拿掉
我就会把这个
这个眼前的停损
拉到我的成本价
我现在还不需要啦
我现在还不需要
我就守住这个边边就好了
这样
好不好
所以如果你是在
在交易的过程中
你先不要管什么违背趋势的这件事
你要管的是眼前的多单
如果你要做空
多单有没有走到这边累了
那累了以后
他自然而然会出现
刚刚我们看到的那个样子
在这边的惯性改变的样子
或是在这边整理整理整理掉一接下来也仍然是惯性改变的样子你会看得出来那你就在等待空单满足区的上面的这个地方的这个点这里
你等这个东西我觉得都没有什么问题
好不好
好 那我们就来回答其他的问题
碰到边界二常常遇到两种状况
关键边缘立刻收回
K棒戳破关键边缘一段距离后又再收回
是否有方法可以判断
遇到两种状况
K棒碰到关键边缘立刻收回
你的意思是指
假设这是关键边缘
你是指K棒
碰一下就直接回去
然后或是碰一下
然后呢
戳破一段距离以后再回去
然后变成下影线这样吗
是否有方法可以判断
你是指事先判断吗
没有方法
我不知道这一次
到底是
到底是哪一种
是碰一下就上去
还是还会戳破再上去
我不知道
但是如果有戳破
对我来讲会更好
像刚刚我在前面这边做的单子
他就是还没有戳破
我就试试看
刚好好案例
叫出我做的单
来
我这边做的这个5K
根本是标准动作
我连加码都加码在这种地方
只是我守均架这个就不见了
这个叫做关键边缘
因为这条黄色的线是开盘架线
那他有没有戳破
没有
但是它长了这样子的脚
那我就试试看手这边
好吧
对吧
然后这一次是戳破了回来
所以我相信这个东西
如果这个东西再把我打掉
我在美股开盘前
我应该就不会下单
因为毕竟现在有9点了
看来要被打掉了
打掉就打掉吧
这样
那你懂我的意思吗
我需要它正确吗
不用
我看到差不多了
风险小小的
打掉了
老鱼你刚刚为什么把风险拉到这里
如果你风险拉到下面
你应该没事
我不知道反正就现在才赔450OK啊这是可以接受的那我今天还有另外一个账号也是刚另外一个账号也是只有打
打早上那一段这一段就只有打这里
这样子
然后还有一个在这边
这个也是打这一个
他现在主要都在玩这一个
只是这个刚刚玩输了
如果风险没有拿掉
没有往上说我是不是就可以
现在就可以躲过了
对吧
我欢喜甘愿的接受了我做了调整的这件事
那有没有可能待会一大根杀下去
还好我少赔一些
对吧
这就是我自己做的结果
然后我就是要接受这件事
亚当满足区出场后
具备什么条件可以再买回
来假设
用我前面的例子好了
吃这边这边有没有满足
这个当例子
这根要翻其实它有满足
这个有满足
他满足了
老鱼你为什么满足还继续赌
因为他前面有这么大的平台
我想要赌他整个平台上去
结果失败了
来假设你亚当满足出场了
这位同学
穷慧同学说出场了以后
什么条件可以再买回
我跟你说超级简单
请你把亚当完全盖住
你只需要回到最原始最原始
其实也是今天投影片的最后一章
回到最原始
你怎么下第一笔多单的
你每一次的多单
判断进场的逻辑跟条件
还有顺序是什么
你就回去问位置对不对
惯性对不对
图对不对
那亚当出场了以后
在这种地方
肯定不会是我继续在这边坐的位置
对吧
那除非这边横盘整理
然后又出现急杀
又上来
又出现这样子
那如果行情都已经重新的出现
我画的这个黄色的地方
那跟刚刚的亚当满足
已经一点关系都没有了
因为他重新的出现了新的迹象
那你只需要把脑袋清空
根本忘记刚刚好脑亚当这件事情
从头来就好
好不好
反而这个上来现在有点尴尬现在9点02分
然后现在的图
这边有上影线
这边有下影线
我用这个案例来当做今天的课程的
算是引导
很好用
眼前的这张图
我先把那个拿掉
因为我觉得
我觉得它有点暗眼
把这个线拿掉
然后这样子
这张图我不打算继续下单
因为在开盘架的上面
跟开盘架的下面
哇
上面有一大堆
这个
下面也有人买
上面有人卖
哇
那这个
像这样子的
我就会犹豫
我就会退一步
想说这没有很好做
因为他掉进来
我测试过了
但是测试失败了
有没有
那我不打算再跟他拼
然后再回头看
如果这整件事情
他发生了位阶注意
位置对了
如果他发生在最底下这边
并且是有把这个边界给打破
哎呦
那我会张大我的眼睛
密切的观察在这个边界的尖尖的
那这个观察的动作
跟我刚刚
关键边界
下去下不去拉回来
跟我在这边做的事情是一模一样的
有没有
我在边界
而且我这根刺的时候我还有看过60k
我知道是隔壁60k的起跑
这里
那这个呢
我也有看过60k
我其实心里面有个底
我觉得那个60k好像快挂掉一样
我这边只要上不去就挂了
这样OK吗
有统计过这个进出逻辑
3000笔以上的交易样本
胜率盈亏比
期望值都在哪个区间吗
没有办法统计
因为我的情绪不一样
我可能今天很开心
明天跟老婆吵架
后天被小孩子烦
然后今天很开心的
说今天的整个状况都对的
然后明天小孩子很烦
然后就把那个气发泄在这边
我的期望值超烂
所以我没有统计这件事情
那如果这位Trader BU同学
如果我今天
给你一个数据
我跟你说
我统计过
三千笔交易
赚赔比希望只是这样子很棒
耶
你也不敢做
因为我不是你
对吧
然后你自己做了老半天
靠
怎么跟老鱼讲的不一样
老鱼骗人
这时候又不一样了
我们两个人之间
我跟网路上这么多网友之间
我们的家庭背景
我们的个性
甚至我们的资金水位
有非常大的差别
有的人比我多好多
他可以做很多很厉害的交易
甚至他怎么凹蛋都没有关系
我不行
对吧
那我要讲的是
就算我给你一套完整的这样子
除非这个是城市交易
才有办法复制
但是城市交易只能复制做法
他不能复制行情
所有的城市他都会告诉你一件事情
过去的绩效不等于未来的绩效
过去台湾是大多头
不等于未来这一年仍然是大多头
所以适用于前面大多头
无脑做多的城市
说不定在接下来的
假设接下来是盘整就好了
那那个城市就会绩效不好
可能还会赔钱
对不对
好吗
所以我没有办法给你一个精准的
这种统计数据
但是我可以给你
如果你真的有想法
你可以把我们这边的影片
你回去追可能十几二十支的前15分钟
每一段直播的前15分钟
同学在问股票
问什么的时候
去看一下那一段子
然后再回来
把我们当时讲的东西回来追踪一下
跟着现在的股票
走势走一下
你可以去验证我们在当下所说的东西
然后当下所做的计划
这样好不好
好来
那打屁股的次数
来
那我们先来聊一下
今天的这个主题
来了
在进主题之前
我想要分享一个
最近才刚收到的一个私讯
这是一位我们以前的同学
哦你看Microsoft,Now,CRM都有在这个同学的雷达上面也跟刚刚大家同学看到的雷达都一样这他今天才传讯息给我的
然后他说他也有买29.4多的SMCI
大家都在看一样的东西
然后他说同学说
前一段时间身边做基本面的朋友
各种追高美光S&DK赚很多
一度怀疑自己
后面静下心来
把两年的股票交易拉出来
发现我就照着做就行了
管他那么多
每年报酬都蛮稳定的
没有爆发式的大赚
但稳定
其实偶尔
你还是会有爆发式的大赚
所以后面就慢慢丢掉
Threads
YouTube上面大家讲基本面的声音
注意力拉回图上面
其实你把你的心思放在图上面
人家在做的股票
你就把它叫出来吗
例如说下来了这时候我要很开心的说我不做了对不对
例如说人家说SNDK来Sandisk
它也是有大跌的时候啊
没有到大跌但是也是有跌下来
我还记得在这段时间我还有刚好有影片有录影到
对吧你就是可以你还是可以找得到跌下来这些地方
按照我们的做法上缘下缘的边界好像下不去
不然1300是一些试试看
我的单子就是这样子建起来的
对吧
然后我自己在我的公司账那边
甚至我的特斯拉
我还有加码
我现在加码到500股
也是在最近的过程中
只是它这个系统好像没有办法显示
那个加码的位置在哪里
反正我的成本在这边
我现在就500股在这边
然后这些是我的持股
然后像Oracle等等这些
反正它也是持股在下面
这样
我看一下直线
我的位置在这里
所以上去回来
满足趋了以后
什么情形下可以重新吃
一样啊
又回到我们刚刚最前面讲的
你什么情形下会吃
而不是在这个地方
直接用我刚刚错过的心态回来吃
好不好
那我要继续的来聊哦
我截这份的截图是要分享给大家你不一定要做期货交易不一定你可以在期货里面练功那你练得好你要继续做期货OK
短线也做要长线学我一样做在IB
也都OK
那如果你要
你要把这套方法拿回去慢慢的做股票
做日线跟周线的股票
你会发现
不难
你就等日线
等哦
等日线打出那个尖尖的
其实
你就可以很轻松的去做它
来
我们今天来聊引线
开头第一张图是在这里
这是一个引线对不对
那我们讲引线的动作是什么
来我先把这个字拉走
大家知道引线怎么来的吗
一根K棒
一开始只有一个价格
中间曾经涨到上面去
然后中间如果被压回来的时候
它就会从上面压回来
我们来看现在的1K
其实这EK不错
EK这里可以玩一下
可以
它来到我今天讲的下边界
好了
来
我们先带大家看一下EK
你看
这个引线
它就是告诉你
曾经价格
刚刚来到这个地方
现在被吞掉了
如果它吞不掉
它变成一个常上引线回来
是不是就代表
卖的人很多
最后
这个一分钟收在这个下面
像这个一样
曾经卖的人很多
他曾经是像这样子的大K棒杀下去
结果盘中开始收脚
收引线收回来
所以引线单纯只有一个人
那其实不重要
那你要看的是
看这个引线发生在哪
例如说
我一秒钟我就已经有直觉告诉我
这边到这边是什么
什么区域来
这边到这边
什么区
满足区
几乎一样
对吧
我刚其实晚的一秒钟
一切过来的那一瞬间
其实可以吃
大概吃在这里
就这里
然后你有吃的人
现在已经可以拉不赔了
你如果吃的话
你会吃在
你应该会吃在这里
对
大概在这附近
然后你现在就要拉不赔了
因为你在1分K里面很短的去读它
这样
上礼拜有同学看丁特有吃PLTR看了他的日線根本就標準圖
對啊就是標準圖啊
你吃799market
那個MRSS同學
是把那個是不是看到就會按下去
對不對好不好
來那我們繼續回來聊影線
我说的是一群K棒放在一起
就我感觉了
什么意思
我跟大家聊一个东西
影线它不是
它不重要
它重要的是它背后代表的意义
你不要被K棒的那个
什么上影线下影线给骗了
它背后的意义是
市场最低阻力的地方在哪
然后我今天试着
把我想要形容的东西
叫AI帮我做一张图
它帮我做成这样子
好可以啦
自然界中
河流高向低流动
额软时见证了
我们理解流动性的起点
能量始终寻求阻力最小的路径
好
他讲的其实没有错
这个两岸
两岸的河流的这个两岸的这个
他就是
就是一个
一个那个石头你知道吗
然后如果市场来到边界
出现剧烈的变化
通常代表很强力的阻力
或是很强力的冲下去的力量
例如说
大家看一下这里
这根
这里本来有好多石头在阻挡这个水流
结果突然间这个水流宣泄而下
而且没有人拿沙包来把它挡住
没有人在这边盖砖块
有人盖砖块的话
它就会出现这种长长的下影线
长长的下影线在这里
但是没有它就穿过去了
对吧
穿到哪里
一直到有人盖出
哦下影线
然后市场就回来了
有没有
那个水流的这一段
我是很认真在讲
我记得哪一本书
其实我忘记了
某一本书里面
它也是有提到
市场会往主力最低的方向
就是水啊
你想想看嘛
水从瀑布下来
甚至瀑布我也可以讲解
还不是都一样
水从瀑布下来
他就自己流
这边遇到一块
一块石头就往这边转弯
这边遇到一个石头就往这边转弯
河流就是这样子嘛
哪一边的石头比较硬
穿不过去他就往这边转弯
是不是
所以眼前的市场就是告诉你
石头在这边
石头在这边而且这个石头盖石头的人
越盖越低
对啦就是你佛摩讲的
越盖越低越盖越低
甚至前面这边
这个水流就是往这边流啊
你懂我意思吗
那眼前的水流往哪里流
很明显这个水流转方向了
因为本来都上不去
你看上不去上不去上不去
哎呦
所以哎呦回来以后
我现在观察的边界不会在这里
我会大概拉在这里
约略
我看一下大颗度的样子
刚好
只是待会的时间有点尴尬
因为
等一下要开盘
开盘
它有可能爆充
有可能上下扫
这个是
是我不知道的事情
对啊
好不好
来我还要继续聊
高雄的王同学
讲到这个
我的确有考虑
再继续办
那个
那个给
给会员同学的聚会
上次我们不是在台中办一次吗
大家有参加的同学
好像感觉好像都还不错
那上次是因为
我说那个场地是
我已经付钱了
我就直接把那个场地拿来用
因为那是本来之前租来要开奖作用的
这样
那如果要开在台北或是高雄
那那个场地
我可能就要额外的租
这样子
那到时候我们大家看场地多少钱
大家现场来的人
直接切一切分掉
这样如何
分掉没多少钱
一个人可能50块100块
场地费分掉就算了
这样好不好
到时候
我是有计划这样子安排
不过应该就是会先
先线那个会员同学先
如果真的有空位
应该不会有
这样好不好
好来
那我说这个剧烈
我把它框起来
剧烈的变化很重要
例如说刚刚这一段
刚好在大家眼前
你知道这三根五分K加在一起
是不是就是一根大的十五分K有没有所以这是一个15分钟剧烈的迹象所以我其实可以预测拆拆看待会的开盘可能往这边走
甚至来突破新高的几率
还蛮高的
因为这个15K的力量
它打破这个边界
不只没有水库的水整个倒下去
没有泄洪
有泄了一些洪
有出来3万口
但是泄洪以后
瞬间又被人家把这个墙壁给补起来
而且补的人
来
补的人
有没有很用力
还蛮用力的
这个引线还蛮长的
代表在单位时间里面
他花了蛮多的力气
甚至通常都会带着成交量
有很多的力气
很多的成交量
把这个边界给盖上去
所以在这个边界里面
我一看就知道有人拿了三万口
在这里盖出一个有三万口来用的墙壁
我不知道以后会不会破
但是我只知道这是破了以后
有人立刻来补血
所以我就拿这个人
他在盖这个的边界拿来干嘛
拿来用
我就赌跟他一起赌
如果他都赌输了
如果哪一天行情真的这样打下来
连这个三万口的人他都挡不住了
那我也赶快跑啊
为什么
因为他三万口如果要倒下来
我只有十口我是会被压死
这样你懂个意思吧
好
再来
我刚刚是不是在上面这边
我做了一个判断
我刚刚说在这个地方
我不喜欢坐在有这些的地方
这个对我来讲
这就是河流
这个是当初的石头
沿岸在这边
结果它掉进来
结果撞了一下上面
哇 出现这样子
所以我其实刚刚后来
我就不想要再往上坐
躲在前面那个点
原因是因为
我发现我一游过去
我就会撞到那个岸边的
很硬很硬的那个墙壁
就是这一道
我一过去就会撞这个
SR同学在东德
Oh my god你有问题你尽量问我尽可能的回答你好不好刚刚1K按816锁805合理吗
我看一下1K哦
你是按在这
锁这里对不对
OK啊
可以啊
你就是要堵这个引线有用对不对
OKOK
来
顺便拿来聊
行情有点怪怪的
你可能要拉个不赔哦
因为
如果这边行情开始长上线
长上线一不小心
其实会再破底的几率就变高了
你的这个地方是破底翻
但是你有点吃晚
对不对
你没有吃到这个边界
你堵这个东西出去
OKOK
好不好
只能照拔的
好啦
我今天讲的这些形容词
我只是要带着大家把
把
很生硬的K棒
你不要去记K棒
你要记的是记K棒背后的
那个水流的样子
水到这边记不记得我刚刚那一秒钟
我说下不去了
有那么一秒有没有
我为什么可以在这个地方
这样子因为我看到这个影线
我刚刚在
5分K我这些单子
我不是在1K吃我在5分K的时候
吃的看一下
我当初吃单的时候我看到什么
来看一下
这里
我吃单的时候我是不是看到各种的影线
对吧
各种的影线
然后我心里面知道一分K大概长那样子
好
我就在赌
所以我是不是就是在赌在这个区域里面
这样懂这种感觉吗
好
那目前看起来刚刚吃在这边的同学
看来你开心
不过他碰到这边的上缘
很容易等一下跑到这边
因为这是我的经验
它左边有这样子的整理
右边还没有
所以右边有可能也会这样子
来回来回的这样子动
好不好
那一根上你线
单独一个人存在
可能不见得有意义
但是如果两根三根四根五根
它慢慢就会形成一个边界
例如
眼前的这里
来同样的边界
这个人在用这个人在用这个人也在用这个人也在用你看市场是不是来到这边开始这一段的涨势开始怎么样开始变弱了
我不知道后面是这样子再往上
还是这样子走平
还是就往下
我不知道
但是有没有看到
刚刚有好多人在用
所以如果你把大家的意愿拉进来
你就知道说
哦 可能这边都有人在用
但是你看哦,这个是1分K的
一分钟在用的人,毕竟少数
5分K在用的边界是不是更大
60分K在用的边界是不是更大
那我们再退一步回来看
我们把这个先关掉
我们再退一步回来看
来
这个边界是15K的边界
同时间也是60k的边界
所以来到这边一定有1分K的人在用
有
但是他同时间也有5分K
也有15k也有60k的人在用
请问
哪一个等级累积的人比较多
累积的砖块比较厚实
哪一个
哦
所以假设今天晚上不小心跑到这里来
这里是不是也是有60分K的人在用
跟15分K的人在用
如果来到这边 你真的还要在这边做多吗
人家套牢在这边的多单没有停损
涨上来了以后 你多单买进去
他刚好卖出给你解套 你帮他解套在这里
所以我们都不去做这种撞墙壁的单子
我等市场像河流一样走出那个边界
然后在边界区域等待我的尖尖的
好,那我这时候来讲了
这其实我们一直都讲过
同样的尖尖的有分
A
A是打破边界的这个尖尖的
B
中间在区域的中间的尖尖的
C
在区域上缘的尖尖的有三个
这三种下影线的力道
哪一个我最喜欢
应该大家一看就知道了
根据刚刚的讲解
甚至刚刚的这个
他就是A
对吧
那我自己中间加码的
来
我加码的那个
那个是加码哦
那不是这不是心肠
加码的那个
它是不是落在哪里
落在最上面
甚至是满足区的这里
所以同样有尖尖的
有有有有这里
这里有尖尖的
但是这个尖尖的发生的位置不对
好不好
然后再来还有
如果一个行情是这样子长上去
在这个地方整理两下出现这种尖尖的
我也不会很爱
虽然我知道可能还会再上一些
但是我找不到我熟悉的下沙整理的这种东西
我找不到
所以这个我会完全的放掉
而且它又出现在满足区
好吗
我刚刚那个会加是因为
是因为我想要赌
我知道要结算
我想要赌那些结算的人
就是前一个月份
六月份在两天内
要结算的合约
得那些空单被嘎到爆炸
我想要赌这件事
结果没有赌成功
没有赌成功
我至少不赔走人
我没有怎么样失败
对不对
有人说1K软掉了
坦白讲1K没有真的软掉
1K变成整理
其实它还
这个底部都还在
底部的边界都还在
除非有某一根K棒像这种
像这种
直接打下来
打下来好啊
打下来就来看这边啊
或是这种
来我们来玩游戏
如果这个地方出现了一个用力撞上去
曾经是大K棒
结果却缩进来变成这样子的K棒
这样子的引线
这代表什么意思
代表这么大的边界
应该引发连锁效应
应该咚咚咚咚咚一路涨上去的
结果不止没有涨上去
空军还有人救援
哇这个人搬了很多砖块来堆叠在这个河岸
这个地方这样子
如果是这样子
后面这边的来的几率就变高很多很多
看来我说的话都会重还没真的烂掉我们大家把眼睛看着看着现在这个1分K我特别带大家看
因为这个1分K
如果它收进去像刚刚那样子
那我其实可以预期的是
后面就很强的上去
9点28而已
还没开盘就这么凶
5K空一个
我看一下
如果你是在5K做空
我不觉得这是好的空点
我为什么会这样讲
这个5K
这是我们刚刚举例的5K
我可以涂鸦得出
惯性的改变
甚至这个边界差不多
这个5K
你做空在这里
我猜你是做空在这附近
840这里
我涂鸦给你看
在你做空的当下
涂是长这样子
你做空的当下
还没下去
对吧
这个第一个
它没有
它没有惯性改变
反而我看到的是
做多的惯性在改变而已
正在改变而已
这样
所以这个5K的空单
坦白讲
我觉得不够聪明
如果你有赚钱
赶快用个不赔
保护自己
好不好
一个好的空单
来
要落在哪里
一个好的空单
拉远看
拉远看搭配开盘价
也不行
如果你要搭配开盘价
你就要在这个地方来
就要在这个5K哦
你要做到这件事情
做到5K的这里
撞上去
瞬间收回来
这里
你要能够在5K逆向涂鸦出一个标准图
5K这里
这里
我可以逆向涂鸦出来
可以耶
有没有
我要能够逆向涂鸦出来
所以这个你的空单不是5K的空单
它是1K以内的事情
这样
9点半刚开
我恭喜你下去了
那你说如果拉远一点你说拉这个这个那就是如果你前面是有赚钱的你前面有赚钱 那我就把我的话收回来因为你有赚钱 你就可以用比较宽松的
这个角度去这边吃吃看 那边吃吃看
对吧 可以的可以的
好不好
那你说老一 但是今天下去的啊
今天下去是一回事
我们必须要让自己在出手前的样子
尽可能维持同一个样子
所以你为了维持那个同一个样子
你可能哪里有些时候会放掉大涨的
有些时候会放掉大跌的
因为你要维持同一个样子
好不好
美股开盘带着成交量
并且跌破了
哇 更大的边界
然后如果它还能够留在这个边界以内
这样子 好不好
那所以我给这位同学
我会建议你
建议你让自己
让自己好好的固定那个出手的同一件事情
你要固定
你要宽心
你放掉这个放掉那个放掉这个放掉那个
没有办法
你这样才有办法固定这件事
这样好不好
玉米秒喷结束
真的吗
玉米
这边的玉米叫什么啊
真的耶
玉米
真的就这样喷完了
好来我们继续看
还有东西哦
来
有人送礼给我
这礼物要干嘛
等一下这个礼物是什么
我第一次看到
我问一下
你送这个礼要花钱吗
如果是要花钱的
不要啦
你说个谢谢
我就感受到了
好不好
一千颗宝石
来
我前面讲的是纯技术面
喂
你们送这个礼物
我能干嘛
我不知道
还是这个礼物
是其他同学可以拿去用的
玉米放了12个小时
代表你前面吃的不错啊
来边界一定对吗一定有效吗在我的标题里面我刚刚的标题我其实是讲要是免费的钻石
免费的就好 那就多送吧
来 有些人在下单的时候
常常会有一个盲点
就是大户专门扫我们的停损
你停损放那么近
摆明就是要被大户给扫掉
你这样子没有意义
你这样就是会被大户都看得到你的停损
我跟你说不用当大户
我想也知道一堆人的停损在这边
在玉米的这边
对吧
我想也知道
对
NQ我要找的是下个月份
因为是一期直播
各位
各位,眼前的K棒,如果現在9點33喔
30分K看起來很兇的樣子喔
我沒有打算要在這裡下多單,沒有
位置慣性圖現在的位置對了
但是慣性對嗎?慣性不對喔
所以我現在會退一步,就這樣子等
那如果他哪一天
不是不用哪一天,如果今天晚上有機會
我们最一开始讲的剧本要来了
如果今天晚上有机会杀下来到这里
来到这个地方
来到306600或650这里
如果有嘿嘿
那我再醒过来就好了
当然那时候我可能睡早了
睡早就算了
我今天就这样子
赔450块就回家睡觉了
但是如果现在这个边界
超级大的60k
打破了
却被收回来
正在收当中
如果是这样子 这么强大6万口7万口的单子居然还可以收回来
哦 那我其实等一下这边就会醒过来
我今天可以用的大概是1000 所以距离我的亏损1000可能还有一次到两次的出手机会
这样子 对吧 那我就等看看嘛
这5分K快收了
1分K到这边 那我其实可以好好观察这边
如果他就这样上去了 就上去啊
老余你放掉了
对我放掉了
所以这5k又是瞬间又是一秒钟
只有一秒钟吃的机会而已
太快了
再度重申有大石头的地方
空单不要在这种人家有大石头的地方去往下撞
不要
OK
来我继续聊
我说是不是陷阱一点都不重要
我前面聊的那些技术面
其实如果没有眼前的
我现在要讲的心态面
搭配起来用
那其实没有意义
为什么
因为你会整天疑神疑鬼
这个阻力那样子
那个人说那只股票怎么样
那个内部人怎么样
这个怎么样
那个外资怎么样
那个内资怎么样
好累哦
是吧
然后开始研究筹码
筹码
台南那边有一群人
哪一个分点的筹码怎么样
你要累死自己
然后你会开始去议测
我知道
你知道
你身边一定有一些朋友
他很会帮股票讲故事
美股为什么大跌
我跟你说
川普说停火是假的
他就会讲很多理论
然后美股为什么大涨
我跟你说
川普真的要停火
反正我现在都乱讲了
我要讲的只是
你身边会有一些朋友
股市涨也好
跌也好
他的理论都一大堆
然后你一坐下来
整个桌子四个人聚餐
他就是所有聊天的主角
你就默默的吃饭
那种通常都赚不到钱
就我看这么多的经验
就是越乳蛇的
会讲自己
哇好厉害
好厉害这样
我不知道你各位身边有没有
我当然不会当面去批评人家
反正我就默默的
他讲他的
我做我的
所以我不在乎是不是陷阱
我只在乎有没有符合我交易的东西
是不是我的进场点
是我就进场防守
防守输了怎么办
停损啊
就停损啊
停损会怎么样吗
打回来就好了
所以重点在于筛选期望值高的交易
也就是说刚刚如果我在另外如果我是要做空的人做空在这个区域就是不聪明的因为人家都已经从
从60分K的大本营走到另外一个大本营
那你还在这边做空
那各位看到这7万口
这7万口是成交量
成交代表有多有空
有多有空
7万口空单就有7万口的多单
所以有人空在这空在30770
他脑袋里想的是美股长这么久了
怎么可能不能跌
跌破了大边界
大M头
他看的是大M头
然后空
对吗
如果你要空大M头
你也空在上面的M这里吧
而不是空在下面的这里吧
对不对
好吗
好多人喜欢看什么大M头
我还记得当初在前一次川普那次股灾的时候
我还跟大家讲说
那个fear and greed index到很低了
眼睛闭着好股票一些就乱买就好了
然后就有人讲说这个是M头很空很空怎么样
然后说六个月后你就知道
六个月后在上面
人呢他已经不知道跑哪去了
对不对
所以你要筛选机会
不是每个下引线
我们刚刚有讲过
不是每个下引线都是我们要的
我们只要筛选在下面的机会
而且我喜欢的是
我超爱的是边界打破以后
后面的这边的这段
我超爱这个
这样
你看刚刚的案例
来边界有没有打破
有
打破收回来
这个5K瞬间就上去
来到这里
这个5分K要收长上引线
来来来
如果这个5分K现在就这样子收起来
带着长长的上引线
身体短短的
上面的壁雷针这么长
后面往这边走的几率
非常非常高
我眼前看的是市场的动态
我不是看K棒
所以这个多单
对不起我不想吃
它牢鱼它又长上去了
我不想吃
因为在我吃的前一瞬间
它居然是这么强烈的这个空法不要我不吃这个怎么样我都不动那什么时候我会动很简单我就重新的涂鸦
评估
所以刚刚这个交易
因为了因为这个上影线
我认为这个边界
它的分数不够
我在我的心中会有一个评分的标准
我用这个60k大边界也加个10分
短线有图加个10分
然后对面是长上影线扣个几分
就是这样子
那我无法跟你说
他精准的就是7分8分16分
没有这种东西
他只是我心里面的一个天品
老鱼你刚刚应该要吃的
可恶
没有啊
我刚刚那一瞬间
我怎么会知道下一根K棒长什么样
我只能照着我当时看到的5K
那1分K呢
也超级摸
我也只能这样讲
就是超级摸的单子
好不好
那如果眼前没有过高
如果这边又再一次下来
我跟你说
如果又再一次下来
这里
破底的几率会非常非常非常非常非常高
好几个非常
所以你不要想说看这边
就可以吃
那如果一分K有两条线
如果它出现在下面
假设待会又杀下来
又杀破这边
然后又杀破一些
又收回来
出现这样子
那我就在这里吃就好
对吧
这个扫很快哦
不要开玩笑哦
老鱼你放掉了
对我放掉
我今天目前没有适合我出手的点
那就只能这样子去睡觉
那怎么办
对吧
学我的交易法以后
无法跟大多数人聊头子
真的
我书的标题如果写
当个交易的据点王
感觉会卖不好他太苦了反正我的意思就是
我用我的交易法
但是他不符合
不符合这些东西就这样子
赚到没朋友
这个标题很可以
所以被扫掉以后如何再次进行
这刚刚其实同学就讲过了
很简单
脑袋清空
如果你前一秒钟
例如说
我讲的KUSO就孵孵孵孵了是不是
对啦
我去打棒球的时候都有一些弟弟
他叫我阿贝
我问你几岁
跟我女儿一样大
好好可以叫我阿贝
好不好
来
所以像现在我能做的规划
我暂时也不知道我要怎么做
我就宽心的看他这样
我要聊的是这件事情
如果你是前一秒被点掉
例如说
你在这边下单
假设你下了这个多单
你要赌这个
结果呢
哇这样子被点掉
点在这里
你前一秒钟被点掉的单子
下一秒钟就要忘记
回归到最原始
第一个事情先评估
我今天是否还有子弹可以用
这样
我是不是还有子弹
还有
好
那第一个check
所以是否还有子弹可以用
check
好打勾了
这里是好的位置吗
60克低档下圆尖尖的好两个check了对吧
但是两个尖尖的这样子惯性对吗
甚至旁边这边惯性对吗惯性不对
惯性的位置对了惯性是不对的
XX图勒有图吗
这里也没有图啊对吧
那所以位置对了惯性不对图也不对
那就等
等什么时候
等市场震荡出我所熟悉的东西
而我所熟悉的东西可能会在
几十分钟后或是半个小时
一小时后震荡震荡震荡这个地方
哦来
这边是不是出现一个长上影线
给刚刚在这边做空的那位同学
待会如果出现在这里
同样的这个迹象
出现在这里
假设有像这样子
这里
你在这里做空
我就会跟你说
这是一个好的空单
有假突破形态的好的空单
因为你有多了一个这个上影线
就在你的前面
帮你撑腰
后面往下跌破的几率就很多
这样有听得懂我的意思吗
你刚刚这张单子刚好
今天是一个很好的叫案
而且这一切刚好都在眼前
那所以你要等哦
你现在不能直接空哦
因为眼前的力量还在往这边走
你要等什么
行情来到这边
一樣來到這裡 開始像這樣子長出這種
長出這種上不去上 像這樣 像這樣
上不去上不去的毛邊 哇 放掉了 放掉了 那個想法拿掉
這根完全拿掉 要做空位置對了
慣性不對 圖也不對 好 拿掉了
然後現在就是直接等 如果要做多 我等兩個地方
一個是這邊上去後回來的這裡
这是开盘架这条线
或是待会震荡后回来的这里
这样
那尖尖的左边大概有这个宽度
所以尖尖的右边这个地方
也可能会有类似的宽度
所以如果你要等尖尖的
如果待会我们等一下下课
如果10点多11点
震荡整理来个下沙来到这里
然后你发现宽度差不多
无法完全一样
这边是21点到21点半
那这边大概就是还要再半个小时
或是一个小时
总之宽度差不多
打出像这样子的东西长在这里
请你不要错过
这个单子会很漂亮
好不好
会是60K边界
然后5K又有这种东西
这样
好吗
黃金喔剛剛大家在做黃金是不是这黄金不要吃哦黄金现在的惯性
各位看一下
这一条隐隐约约的影线
它是不是界定出一些边界
来我们的投影片
影线界定出来的边界
不对
影线界定出来的边界在哪里
边界在这里
有没有
边界这么多引线界定出来的边界
他掉进来了
变成上有压下有撑
我不会在这里做多单哦
好不好
请问杨明明天可以all in吗
这些你是要故意要给我讲的
明天吗
明天还不错
可以吃但是你说all in我就不要啦
不要all in
有人有问题
底部是尖尖的底部是大颗度的底
跟小颗度尖尖的隔壁怎么选
来
大颗度尖尖的
就会是小颗度的破底翻
所以如果
大颗度
大颗度哦
在这个地方尖尖的
你肯定
好啦对不起我收回
几乎
可以在这边找到一个小小的
破底范的样子
这样
刚刚就是一个好案例啊
刚刚的小娜
小娜
有没有
这个
你说他有破底范啊有啦他勉强其实有只是因为他刚刚太凶
如果前面这根没有这么凶这里我就吃了
这样懂这种感觉吗
大颗度
我们看60k
大颗度的边界
例如说像这种
这种他这边一定就有
或是说前一段时间这个更偏
这个超漂亮
这一段
在前一天的这里
大颗度的边界尖尖的
肯定就会是短格局
一定有破底翻的东西让你吃
好不好
怎么突破世代同堂
一年生一个
不是最近有那个生十个的妈妈吗我真的是跪下来拜超佩服我生3个我已经
我已经不行了
10个
为什么ES比小娜更不容易被少
很简单啊
小娜平均每一档的挂单量不大
小SP一档的挂单量是
几千口几百口算少
一檔的挂单量是几千口
然后小那一檔的挂单量10口20口
所以自然而然小SP比较波动率比较不会那么大
好不好
SpaceX噴了
这不用理他啦
这个我跟你说
他会回来的
假设现在噴到400
奔到400是怎麽樣 奔到400跌回250
再從250重新做就好
前面這一段就給他
各位眼前這麽多支股票
你每一支股票的IPO都有跟到是不是
我沒有一支股票的IPO有跟到
所以勒 那有差
對 反正就是盤口很厚
對 概念就是這樣子
身旁的同學都在炫耀
我也可以炫耀我买了两股
我说了
我买这两股不是为了赚钱
我只是为了让它出现在我的持股清单里面
这样
我只是为了这样子
我不打算买
但是就算是这样
我也还是吃在
吃在边界的下缘
老习惯改不掉
这样
好不好
那我的长线的小纳
我已经下的已经是下一个月的合约了
所以其实我就没有打算
没有打算干嘛
就这样抱着吧
来同学看东西
想象工作是帮客户不是自己的
很好啊这样很好啊
很好很好这个想法很好
那如果你有机会从市场上赚到钱
记得偶尔还是要出金
钱拿一些回来
要犒赏这个很辛苦的基金经历人好不好把钱脱钩是很棒的事情台积6月11月60k11点内跟买在2230
我看一下
台积
买在这边对不对
买的漂亮耶
可以耶
可以耶这个买的漂亮
可以可以 60K 給過好東西好東西
SMP指數比較容易做
來我們同時間來看
我們叫出來看就知道了
例如說
都叫小型的好了
同樣的
是他剛叫出來需要調一下K棒
小到窮 通常也比較不少一點
那小SB是最不少的 你看一下他的60K
或是你來看 我們同樣看短線好了
我把他的短線跟
來我們兩邊都看1K
兩邊在1分K
的掃檔 你看喔 這邊
破底破很多
这边其实比较没有破那么多下去
有没有
当然我平常不会这样子去比较
我只是要跟大家讲
一个背着比较重的厚度
比较重的这个山
比较不容易动
小那它就是很活泼乱跳
而且它全世界的资金
都在科技股里面
对吧
所以自然而然它就很容易乱跳
很容易这样
这边扫一个上一线
那边扫一个下一线
好不好
我刚刚旁边Peter报了很多股票哦
然后所以大家自己看
有些股票其实都不错的
来
UP吃在
好我们看一下UPUP是什么
UP
Wheelsup
我好像曾经你有叫我看过这个
对不对
你吃在哦这个呼范很便宜很漂亮啊
这呼范很漂亮啊
吃在6月10号
我相信你一定是吃这边
对啊
很好很好
没有什么问题
什么样的边界叫做有大人称
你这个边界就是你有日线等级的边界
这不就是大人在称腰的意思吗
日线等级的互换
对呀
像我们刚刚看的来刚刚看的短线
刚刚看的短线像这个
这个互换称腰的人850称腰的人就比较多
为什么
我往左边一对过来
好多人有一个平坦的
所以如果是我平常在做1K
这附近我可能还会测试
因为它这个边界够平
然后够宽
而且还没有真的
真的喷出过
没有这样子过
好我可以读读看
因为它够平够宽
这样子
那这样子是不是代表
这个边界不是只有1分K的人在用
可能5分K的人有好几个在用
15K有好几个
那如果你是日线的边界
是不是就是日K等级最大的边界
这样好不好
所以同样的道理
有人问说
为什么我会在日线的这边建仓
我的长线的小纳就是在这边建起来的
建仓的理由很简单吧
这就是日线的边界
对吧
这样可以吗
就是日线的边界
所以这里就一定有大颗度帮忙撑腰
如果短颗度也看到停不住
就啪啪啪就吃
我才吃七口的小鈉
然后可以赚3万块钱
然后我520到6月出头
前面那一段赚2万多
这边这样赚3万
不够吗
我没有吃大单
我就轻松的这样吃
我其实还留着余地是我想要
结算后看我们震荡整理
我再重新再加码再干嘛的
这样好不好
然后历程6月16 30k历程
等一下我这边先截图一下
不然等一下忘记
看一下
各位如果你身边有朋友还没订阅老鱼的帮忙叫他订阅一下
好不好 我有准备礼物要现场抽给大家
就是10万那一周的直播会抽奖这样 好吧来我们来看一下你说历程下次给我号码好不好因为我背不起来各个股票的
得那个
历程
你要问的是问什么呢
6月16日30K9点半那一根
来我跟你说
我从来没有看过股票的30K
一次都没有
我的股票最短是看60k
所以我是60k跟日线在做
甚至我很习惯看周线
所以你应该是做多
对不对
买在329
你买在这边吗
我在猜329应该在这里
如果单纯从60k或30k的图
是啊可以给过
有互换可以给过
但是你心里要有底
你买的这个位阶是很高的
你说老于高低是相对的
我知道
但是眼前他的惯性已经掉下来
甚至前面这边到340几
360这附近都有人在买
好不好
这个要小心
如果你买在329
那现在有赚到钱
现在346吧
心里有个底
跌回成本
我宁愿你成本走
好不好
拜托
这个一旦不小心
整个掉下来就很恐怖
还有什么
CVX
大家在爆股票就对了
Chevron
这就是
这就是大科度的边界
那我进到小10K看一下
如果你要等小10K的人
你其实可以等这边有能力
有能力创一个高
再回来以后的这边会好很多很多
好不好
眼前的小10k是一个十字线
所以搭配上它的日线
也还没有到完全标准的标准图
所以这个我会列为观察清单
但是不会立刻就在这里吃下去
这样可以吗
ENPH周K小美
ENPH
这什么东西啊能源股周周K的确是在这个重要的边界
好 那我们来到日线看一下
嗯 日线也的确有两个下影线
你要做一个抉择就是
这上面有一些压力对吧
虽然说压力是在57块 现在在52
大概10%左右的压力这样子
就是10%以后
所以你要就是心里有个抵押的这附近
而且目前看起来
其实这边可能还要震荡一段时间
这张图也没有日线的标准图
所以我最喜欢的反而是
如果哪一天有一个日线
是瞬间这样杀下去
像这样子
像这样子回来的日线的隔壁
这个我会很喜欢
刚好又打在周线的地方
但是他现在这样子在这里
我就不见得会很爱
好不好
NA Nasa日线配周线是不是不错
我们看一下Nasa
说很多人跑去吃Nasa
然后说因为它有包含什么
Space的股票
我看一下哦
日线哦
周线在这个地方
它好像没有太多的K棒可以看
顶多就这样子
是说这边不会到太差
这倒是真的
而且他有惯性回来以后
回到这个地方
其实你有个底
反正就是上面吃少一点
下面吃多一点
抓个大框框的概念
抓周线在这边停顿
然后就慢慢吃
好不好
好了
急问
为什么急问
好这边有疾问跟雄慧同学的
我们都拿出来聊一下
来先看疾问的3036
这个
我按照什么
好好好 翻回来了
6月8号翻亚当
满足是不是约200
同事买在290我准备吸他的鞋你是只这样子下对不对差不多啊差不多而且你吸他血的地方
你说200有点远
你大概可以关注的是
这附近快要停住了
吸他的血
哇
果然有得到我们的精髓
就是当坏人
关门放狗的那个坏人
哈哈
新唐
昨天收盘
够翻亚当的标准吗
你卡住了
昨天收盘
这根吗
来
够翻亚当吗
可以啊
但是
你不用卡
来
他翻出去告诉你
隔壁要继续往上走
但是隔壁没有往上走
那就告诉你 这边有压力
你不会吃在这吧
各位注意哦 翻亚当我们是 例如说突破区间
我们是把这个段翻出去 对吧 这样子翻出去
我话好丑 重来 这样子 对不对
不是进场在这里哦
我们都是进场在
在下面的地方堵这一段翻出去
然后出厂在这里的地方
我们是做这件事情
我们不会在这里进厂
然后堵他翻亚当
然后现在才在烦恼
说怎么办怎么办
翻亚当只是一个
如果市场有来到这里
我可以怎么做计划的出厂计划
千万不能拿来进厂
好不好
你是5月20号吃的
哦
如果你吃在这边
那你吃的很好啊
那亚当前面的这个亚当已经到了
那是说这个亚当到了以后
整理以后的下亚当也到了
所以现在
我这里要问这位穷慧同学
你当初的计划是什么
你现在是不是害怕它跌下来
你想要问我说怎么办
不对啊
你当初的计划是什么
我如果叫你明天卖掉
那如果明天在這裡賣掉以後後天漲上去
挖
那我如果叫你不要賣
那如果跌下來
挖
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕